so thanks for the introduction
and also thanks to the organizers for
putting this network shop together this
is joint work with shusun Wang who's now
at Stevens Institute and Michael Mahoney
and this workshop brings together people
from a lot of different research
specialties so I'm not going to assume
that everybody necessarily knows a lot
about the bootstraps I thought it would
be kind of helpful to make some very
high-level remarks so conventionally in
statistics the way we think about the
bootstrap is it's just sort of a general
tool to do inference on randomness and
data and we often think of it as
something that's being that's
computationally intensive in fact
sometimes the word computationally
intensive methods is used as a keyword
to label research papers on bootstrap
methods the perspective I'm gonna take
in this work is almost reversed so I'm
going to use the bootstrap to do
inference on randomness in an algorithm
and also the goal will be to use the
bootstrap to enhance computation so
again this is sort of a very unusual way
of thinking about the bootstrap from a
statisticians point of view another
thing is that the bootstrap is just an
extremely flexible and general purpose
tool and I think there's a lot of
potential for it's sort of broad
application in randomized numerical
linear algebra and related fields so I
kind of wanted to use this talk as an
opportunity to sort of sell that point
to this community and to sort of
underscore this I want to sort of share
an amusing remark that's at the very end
of Efron's 1979 seminal paper on the
bootstraps if you read all the way to
the very end this is the last sentence
of the paper he says I also wish to
thank the many friends who suggested
names more colorful than the bootstrap
including Swiss Army knife meat axe and
my personal favorite the shotgun which
to paraphrase two key can blow the head
off of any problem if the statistician
can stand the
helping mess I think nowadays we can
tolerate the mess a lot better than they
could in 1979 just due to the fact that
distributed computing is becoming
ubiquitous so I think the bootstraps a
pretty cool thing I don't really need to
go through this slide very carefully in
light of everything that's been said in
the past two days so we all know that
randomized numerical linear algebra has
been intensively steady now for quite a
while and there have been highly
optimized algorithms and so on but of
course in exchange for getting these
speed ups over over more traditional
algorithms we pay a price which is we
have to tolerate some random error all
right and this is the issue I really
want to focus on so if we compute some
randomized solution how large is the
error for that particular solution okay
not in the worst case not in some other
you know general sense for this
particular solution that's the air that
I want to study so the prevailing sort
of theoretical viewpoint in this area
has been to derive theoretical bounds
describing the errors of solutions and
this is a very useful thing it gives us
a lot of insight into the factors that
influence the quality of the output but
there's some sort of essential
limitations to this kind of approach so
often it's done from a worst-case point
of view so it may be pessimistic for any
particular problem the bounds often
involve constants which maybe even if
you can we'll Whittle them down to
something nice they are often still
conservative or even worse they could
involve unknown constants and likewise
they typically do not take advantage of
the structure that may be unique to your
given problem so for these reasons it's
often difficult to use these theoretical
bounds in any sort of numerical sense in
a given problem and so what I want to
pursue is an alternative so I want to
numerically estimate the area of a given
solution and in certain areas of applied
math this approach has a name it's often
called a posteriori
error estimation so in in areas like
numerical PDEs or finite element methods
this is a fairly well-developed thing
there there even some textbooks written
on it in numerical linear algebra
randomized numerical linear algebra
maybe not so much there are there are a
handful of papers that have considered
this at least a little bit and in fact
among these few references some of the
people who are here but nevertheless I
would I would say that it's safe to say
that this approaches underdeveloped and
there's quite a bit of potential to
explore what you can do with it you know
in broader variety of algorithms so I'm
just going to focus on two sort of
prototypical linear algebra methods or
algorithms so do some matrix
multiplication at least squares and I'm
gonna break the talk into more or less
two disjoint pieces okay so outline the
set up so I have two extremely tall
matrices a and B they're deterministic
okay so in all the problems I'll
consider the inputs I'm viewing as
deterministic even though they could
obviously be data I'm not going to
consider that source of randomness I'm
only going to focus on the randomness
and algorithm and or the randomness in
the bootstrap method that I'll propose
okay so the number of rows is in that's
a very large number the number of
columns is d it's relatively small
compared to in it could be large an
absolute sense and let's say we want to
compute a transpose B all right all
right so as we know the cost of ordinary
matrix multiplication is n times d
squared and we want to bring that down
so we do I guess what's now I guess
commonly known as a sort of a sketch and
solve kind of thing so we'll form
sketches out of the original matrices a
and B I'll use the letter T to denote
the sketch size so I'll bring the the n
rows down to T and I'll denote the
sketches as a tilde B tilde and for the
purposes of the bootstrap there's really
only two basic properties that I'll need
for the sketching matrix so I'll just
need that the
affected gram matrix is the identity and
that the rows of the sketching matrix
are essentially independent okay
conceptually that's really all that
matters when you look into the fine
grained details when you derive bounds
and so on there are some different
technical consequences for different
choices of sketching matrices but I
think that's sort of a second-order
consideration so how do we choose T okay
so there's a direct relationship between
the choice of T and the quality of the
sketch product all right so of course
the quality is going to improve as T
gets bigger and that's essentially a
consequence of the law of large numbers
so if we expand the gram matrix out as a
sample average of rank one matrices
independent rank one matrices okay and
we know that the expectations the
identity this is going to get closer and
closer to the identity with high
probability and therefore the sketch
project is going to get closer and
closer to the true one all right so
that's that's clear at a conceptual
level but what does this actually look
like in a real example I think this is
this plot gives a lot of insight into
what's going on at a sort of in a sort
of statistical way so let's focus on the
Left plot first the way I've generated
this plot is as follows so I incremental
II add one row at a time to a sketching
matrix each time I add a row I compute
the exact air for that particular sketch
against the true product so of course
this is not something you can do in
practice this is just to illustrate
what's going on
so as you expect the air generally
improves as the sketch size gets bigger
but there's some fluctuations along the
way now you can imagine repeating that
entire experiment many many times and
that's what the right plot shows so the
right plot shows many independent copies
of the sample path that's on the left
and you see there's actually quite a bit
of variation and so I mean want another
way to think of this is each person in
this room could have their own sample
path and so this reflects the quality of
all of our
sketch estimators in aggregate and it
any given sketch size what any one of us
wants to know is you know what's what's
an appropriate air level such that I'm
likely to be below that for some tunable
probability okay so you know there's a
name for that it's called a quantile or
let's say the 99th percentile that's
what the thick black curve is right and
I think this quantile function or
quantile curve is a very useful way of
thinking about the trade-off in a in a
sort of very quantifiable and estimable
way all right and I'm going to use the
the letter epsilon sub T to denote the
random error I think conceptually the
the choice of the norm doesn't matter so
much I mean the scaling will change etc
but I think I would say as long as the
norm or error functional more generally
is a smooth functional then this kind of
picture arises and in fact this is a
very very generic sort of thing so I
mean I've done things with random
forests I've done things with least
squares this is sort of very generic ok
all right so I'm gonna call the quantile
function Q sub 1 minus alpha of T so the
the probability that I'd like to have
for an air bound let's say is 1 minus
alpha and if we had access to this
quantile function we could do two things
with it so for a given sketch size it
gives us a particular bound with high
probability that there's another way we
could use it which is sort of a in a
predictive sense so if we have some air
tolerance that we'd like to achieve this
quantile function will allow us to look
ahead and forecast what sketch size
we'll need to get to in order to achieve
it so both of these are I think are
interesting and this is what I'd like to
estimate so that's the sort of the
well-defined statistical problem that
I'm proposing to so if I want to
estimate this function and here's why
it's not easy so I constructed this
thick black curve based hypothetically
upon many
experiments right but in real life we
only get one a tilt in one Beto's
generally or at least that's what we
want we only want to run the sketching
algorithm once so it might seem almost
impossible that you could approximate
this thing that comes from many repeated
experiments just from a single
experiment and that possibility is in a
sense what is so remarkable about the
bootstrap okay so the bootstrap is what
makes it possible to do that and another
important consideration is that we're
computationally constrained right I
don't have an infinite amount of
resources to compute this quantile
function even if you know I come up with
something clever it needs to be cheap
enough so that it doesn't outweigh the
benefit of doing sketching in the first
place okay so I'll definitely keep track
of this cost as things go along and
again just to make this point clear we
never get to see any of these curves in
practice okay so this is just for
illustration all right so let me give
you just a little bit of intuition for
how the bootstrap algorithm will work so
let's imagine for the moment we could
generate independent copies of the error
variable of course we can't do that in
particular because it depends on the
true product but if we could let's say
we could generate a hundred samples well
we could take the second largest of them
and that would be a natural estimate of
the 99th percentile you know that would
be quite effective of course we can't do
that so what in essence what the
bootstrap tries to do is to generate
pseudo samples of this variable playing
simple and then once we generated enough
pseudo samples we'll take the quantile
of those alright so here's the algorithm
I could fit it easily all in one slide
so the input is an integer M that's the
number of samples I'm going to generate
and then the only other inputs are just
the a till then the B total all right so
here's the loop I'll draw a vector of
numbers without replacement from the set
one through T I'll take those indices
and then I'll plug them into my sketches
and I'll use those to form or I'll take
rather the rows of a till then be till
the index by these random integers and
that will give me two new make
these eight till the star and B tilde
star so there's going to be replicates
of some of the rows of a tilde B tilde
in the start versions then I'll take the
norm of the difference between the
started product and the unstart one and
I'll view this as a pseudo sample so for
each iteration of the loop I get one of
these stars pseudo samples then after
the loop is done I take the desired
quantile of those samples so this is the
whole thing it's really that simple so
maybe I should pause for just a moment
in case there any questions so I mean I
guess it depends on how you want to
formulate the problem so there are other
ways certainly you know you could look
at variants instead of quantiles that
makes a lot of sense too but I mean if
if we agree that our goal is to estimate
that population level quantile function
then taking the empirical quantile is
sort of a natural thing but there are
other there's certainly other things you
could try you just regenerate many
replications although schedule matrix
then you get B star rather than you
stopped sample right but so indeed so
that would almost that would basically
be what I was mentioning here so if you
if you see you're saying do actual
sketching many times but the center is
not a transpose BH oh I see what you
mean yes yes you could do that I believe
though that that the resampling is
actually much cheaper and we'll get into
that maybe more in a second yeah so in
particular yeah you're not going to have
to generate a new sketching matrix
you're not going to have to do any new
matrix multiplication with a new
sketching matrix that's kind of baked
into the sampling mechanism definition
was to find out that
so this thing wouldn't really find that
collision of this particular scene it
would just find out that because he was
getting tee times over the fact it would
get effectively give me independent
copies of that variable roughly so they
back I I could imagine that working but
it wouldn't indeed it wouldn't give me
an error estimate for this particular
sketch but it would it would give some
reasonable way of approximately in the
quantile function okay so just move on
all right so just to be accurate and how
I present this project in the paper we
analyze a slightly different version so
there's many flavors of bootstrap if you
will so this is what's sometimes called
the multiplier bootstrap in the
statistics literature at a conceptual
level there's not really that much stuff
that's different going on in essence the
sampling is done using Gaussian
variables this is really just for
convenience of analysis if you do
experiments the results are effectively
the same so I'm just mentioning that so
just so you don't get confused if you
look up the paper and there there are
some interesting differences but at a
high level that this is not so different
so I won't go into the details but
there's a relatively simple way to see
why this is mimicking the previous
bootstrap symptom okay so now I have an
algorithm but how much does it cost so
what I want to argue here is that
there's a really simple but effective
way to dramatically reduce the cost of
sort of this basic bootstrap that I just
proposed and this is based on
extrapolation so in applied math or
numerical analysis extrapolation is a
very classical idea so the thing I'm get
it getting out here is closely related
to Richardson extrapolation so the
central limit theorem tells us that this
quantile function should scale like 1
over square root of T ok and that's
that's really useful because what it
means is if we could estimate a point
very early on on this quantile curve
then we can just rescale to get
everything there
after all right and what's kind of
amazing is that as simple as that is it
works really well okay so so this so
let's say I generate some little
sketches of size T not those are going
to be poor sketches but I can still
apply the bootstrap to those and get an
estimate and then I just rescale for all
T that are larger and so yeah so
basically I would be estimating a point
here
even though ultimately I'd probably want
to sketch size out there so this T
naught is just sort of an expedient
right so this is a delicate question I
mean the T naught needs to be of some
moderate size right I mean is you want T
naught to be maybe at least 50 or 100 it
doesn't need to be huge but it can't be
just right so so I'll have a few
comments about the analysis later so the
analysis that involves a lot of things
but all right so let's be a little bit
more detailed about the cost so the cost
of sort of generic sketching algorithms
for matrix multiplication looks
something like this
so you the cost of doing ordinary matrix
multiplication on the sketches and then
you have this additional term that comes
from implementing the sketch itself so
for instance in the case of randomized
Hadamard that's what the second term
looks like and this is the cost of the
bootstrap so at each iteration of the
bootstrap loop I do ordinary matrix
multiplication and that gives me the t
naught times d squared and then I do
that M times so basically what I want is
for this cost to be no greater than the
first one and that happens as long as
the number of bootstrap samples is not
too large okay so here you can see why
the extrapolation helps because it says
that as long as the initial sketch size
is relatively small compared to what
I'll altom utley need for an accurate
sketch then that gives me a quite a bit
of runway for picking a decent number of
bootstrap samples and what's empirically
nice so this I'm just making an
empirical statement here is that in a
lot of problems
20 bootstrap samples is perfectly
adequate okay so so this you know
there's not there's no there's nothing
sneaky going on here okay so it's it's
cool in fact you could almost think of
the number of bootstrap samples as being
oh one for practical purposes maybe
logarithmic or something okay and
furthermore we're assuming in is large
right so it is much much larger than d x
then a small initial sketch size we're
in good shape okay so the this so you
can use an interpolation rule so I think
for the second largest among twenty
samples is going to be equal ninety
seventh or eighth you know it's gonna be
it's not going to be quite ninety nine
but there's a there's a there's a if you
use MATLAB or something
there are simple interpolation rules to
get the night you know it's a this is a
very minor detail but indeed that that's
a legitimate point so okay I'll just say
a few comments about the theory there's
a lot that could be said about the
results in this paper and in fact most
of the paper is theoretical
so to formulate the performer to
describe the performance of the
bootstrap in a non asymptotic way sort
of require some care so here's here's
kind of a natural way of doing that so I
have a random variable whose
distribution I'm interested in and I can
consider the distribution of the
bootstrap sample conditionally on the
sketch that I drew and if you compare
those two distributions in a metric
there's typically a direct way of
relating that to the distance between
their quantiles
alright and i scaled them by a factor of
square root of t just in the interest of
making comparisons with central limit
theorem this is just sort of a technical
thing and the types of sketching
matrices for which the theory works
there's there's a variety you can do iid
sub Gaussian it's maybe somewhat
idealized but still interesting you can
do length sampling and the theory
also applies to randomized hedemora
transform here's what one of the results
looks like in the sub galaxy encase just
because it's a little bit simpler I'm
using the entry wise maximum absolute
value norm as my norm for the error
variable okay certainly we could talk
about exploring other norms but even as
simple as that Norman may seem the
theory is surprisingly involved and this
is what the distance between the
bootstrap distribution and the actual
distribution looks like with high
probability
right so the this distribution here on
on the right that's a random probability
distribution and therefore this distance
is a random variable and you know I can
concede that maybe you know in the
context of numerical linear algebra it's
the shape of this bound might look a
little unusual in the high dimensional
statistics literature when analyzing
problems involving multiplier bootstrap
methods this type of bound is actually
not so uncommon so I think it's
important not to take the exponents in
it in too literal of a sense I think
first pass the way to think about this
is there's a problem dependent scale
factor there's a dimension dependent
factor and there's a sketch size and
basically the result at a minimum is
telling you as long as the sketch size
is sufficiently large compared to these
other two factors the bootstraps going
to work okay so the matrix entries by a
million indeed so there's I mean it's
it's natural that you should have a
problem dependent scale factor because I
mean if if you change units it's gonna
be you know if used if if you blow
everything up it's gonna be a lot harder
to get a good accuracy so I think maybe
it would be simpler if you if you scale
things so that these norms are are one
even yeah I don't I don't I don't think
this is something to worry about too
much but I think it's it's it's not
unexpected there was a problem dependent
scaling
yes and also I mean this function H is
is a little bit you know where does that
come from why is that there so let's
let's not spend too much time on this
there's a lot of other theory in the
paper that I'm not going to talk about
and also I mean there's there's some
there's some interesting ideas that I
wish I could talk about which I think
are novel contributions but in the
interest of time I'll skip over all of
that oh right so the the lady Prokhorov
metric so there's actually a variety of
there's a whole bunch of probability
metrics or metrics on probability
distributions that you can think about
there are have different advantages and
disadvantages this one is a particularly
nice one because it met Rises weak
convergence or a sequence of random
variables converges in distribution if
and only if the distributions converge
with respect to that metric so this is
sort of a natural one and it also
relates naturally the quantiles
but that's a minor point okay so let me
say something empirical and I think in
some ways this is the one of the more
exciting slides so here's here's what's
going on the two plots just refer to two
different kinds of sketching matrices so
the experiment on the Left involves
random randomized Hadamard transform the
experiment on the right involves length
sampling my full matrix a is 60,000 rows
and about 800 columns I'm using an
initial sketch size of 390 that was
chosen just because it's half of deep so
390 is obviously a lot smaller than the
full number of rows 60,000 so that shows
you that you can really start out with
quite crude sketches the number of
bootstrap samples as I mentioned earlier
I'm gonna take to be 20 so really what's
going on is I take to really small
sketches I apply the bootstrap all right
the black curve represents the true
quantile function at every T the blue
curve is the mean of the bootstrap
estimates over many repeated experiments
the green and the yellow are one
standard deviation away
okay so here is where the bootstrap
actually gives us one estimate and the
rest is all from the extrapolation so I
think this is that kind of kind of
remarkable that we can predict quite
accurately what's going to happen well
past 10,000 starting out with only 400
okay so the extrapolation is a really
useful thing and again it works kind of
regardless of what kind of sketching
matrix you use I mean there's a little
bit of dependency you can look at those
details in the paper but more or less
the details of the sketching matrix are
not so critical experiment and you're
too scared like this is rejected by you
know one over a thousand yeah yes so
indeed so I forgot to mention in this
experiment we scaled the the gram matrix
so the largest absolute value is 100 so
indeed yes yes if I just as submitted
zero how much am I getting that expected
error is going down as well so so you
say you're saying if the a matrix is
zero no no if I estimate how much air
I'm gonna get between a tilde B true
until the transpose B minus a transpose
B right and I just estimate that air is
zero as my plot can look like this or is
it gonna be dramatically worse so I so
so I mean in in fewer words are you
asking if the estimate is vacuous I
don't think so I mean so
I need to think for a few minutes to
give you an accurate answer to that but
I don't think zero is gonna so how can
you design some sampling scheme or
projection random sketching to respire
that structure is there any way there's
a lot of things that can be done with
that's a good that's a that's a good
idea what's nice about the bootstrap is
in a lot of ways it's agnostic to the
structure of the matrix it works
reasonably well for a lot of things I
imagine there's possible improvement
that you get in structured cases but
that's something I haven't looked into
in detail so I don't actually have a lot
of time left and there's still the
entire least-squares portion so just
just bear with me and I'll try and get
through the the important points quickly
okay so in the least-squares case I'm
going to look at at all a matrix a long
B vector and I want to solve an
overdetermined
least squares problem again and it's
much much larger than D I'm going to use
the sketches and an important point is
that okay there's more than one type of
sketching algorithm you can use to solve
this problem there's the sketch and
solve kind of thing do two journaiist
Mount Mahoney and mythic Christian
there's more recent proposals that are
sort of more like quasi Newton methods
but what I think is really interesting
is even though these algorithms are
quite different the bootstrap still
accurately estimates the airs of either
of them so you get to take your pick in
the bootstrap will still do its job okay
so I think that's enough here the
problem formulation I'll think about in
the least-squares case is pretty much
the same I want to estimate the
quantiles of the air vert okay now again
you can you can pick it some norm on the
solutions the quantile function will
depend at a technical level on that norm
but let's not worry about that for now
okay so you know we have this intuition
for the bootstrap that we're generating
pseudo samples in the least squares case
I think a nice idea to keep in mind is
that you
thing of the bootstrap as doing
something sort of in a parallel universe
where the original sketch solution in
the parallel universe is playing the
role of the true exact solution and the
bootstrap is sort of constructing this
perturbed kind of scuffed up version of
the sketch and it's the difference
between the scuffed up version of the
sketch and the sketch it's statistically
similar to the fluctuations of the
actual error variable then that's a way
of thinking about about the bootstrap
then if it is doing its job okay here's
the algorithm so this is more or less
the same template that I described for
the first version of the bootstrap so
I'll draw T numbers with replacement
from the index at 1:30 I'll use those
indices to extract a new set of rows
from the original sketches or entries of
the vector B tilde I'll solve the
Associated least squares problem with
the starred inputs okay that will give
me a starred solution then for that
particular iteration of the loop that
will give me one bootstrap sample by
taking the norm of the difference
between the starred solution and the
unstirred one then after I've done in
the iterations of the loop I'll again
take the desired quantile of those
numbers okay now the gaussian multiplier
bootstrap that I described earlier
actually is not appropriate in this
setting that it is important that I do
the sampling without replacement in this
setting but that's just something you
mentioned and one other thing is that
this template more or less works in the
same way for the iterative Hessian
sketch algorithm there's a few minor
details that have to be modified but it
looks more or less the same
computational cost a lot of the same
high-level remarks apply again so one
important thing is that the cost of the
bootstrap is independent of the large
dimension in that's great because it
means
it's highly scalable and there's an easy
way to see that just because the
bootstrap never sees the full inputs it
only sees the sketches again in the
least-squares case 20 bootstrap samples
is typically adequate I didn't mention
this detail before but the bootstrap
samples can be generated in an
embarrassingly parallel manner they none
of the bootstrap samples have to talk to
each other
furthermore the communication cost is
pretty small because you're only
communicating the sketches and it's in
fact it's even better than that because
you're only communicating the initial
sketches so those are quite small
matrices is something you could do on a
laptop perhaps and even better in the
least-squares context the bootstrap
computations have free warm starts
because at each iteration the bootstrap
loop you're solving a new least squares
problem the bootstrap solution is going
to be close to the original sketch
solution and therefore you can use the
original solution as a warm start if you
choose to
so right so so here are some plots I'm
using extrapolation here as before in
the Internet of hestian sketch I'm going
to use a linear extrapolation rule
rather than the square root of T rule
that I described earlier and that's just
because this particular algorithm has a
linear rate of convergence that's all
I'll say we have some we have some
reasonable theory I don't have time to
get into so I'll just make some closing
remarks the bootstrap is a flexible
approach to error estimation that can be
adapted to a variety of problems it
provides a practical alternative to
worst-case analysis and it's naturally
adapted to the input set you actually
have the cost of the bootstrap is not
outweigh the benefits of sketching and
in fact there's a lot of ways to speed
it up you can use extrapolation the
computations can be parallelized etc and
the numerical performance is encouraging
and it's supported by theoretical
guarantees we have some papers there's a
paper of matrix multiplication and the
least squares which just came out in
ICML I also have a paper quite different
from this that uses the same ideas in
the context of random forests and that
will appear at annals of statistics
later this year so thank you
[Applause]